Let's solve a few tasks that contain fractions.
Instead of fractions, we can actually say "rational numbers."
Whatever.
I will solve each of these examples here above.
Let's start with (b).
We have 2/3 minus 1/4.
As with fractions, we need to bring it
to a common denominator here.
We need to know how many parts
of all we work.
We look for a common denominator at 3 and 4, or at least
total fold of 3 and 4. The smallest number,
which is divided into both is 12.
Let me write it this way.
Let me do it this way.
That would be more interesting.
For 2/3 we record 12 in denominator. 3 in 4 equals 12,
and 2 in 4 equals 8.
These two fractions are equivalent.
We multiplied the numerator and the denominator by 4.
For 1/4, if we get 12 in a denominator,
then 4 by 3 equals 12,
then 1 in 3 is equal to 3.
3/12 and 1/4 are the same thing.
And here we have a minus sign.
This will be equal to 8 minus 3 on 12,
which is the common denominator,
and this is equal to 5/12.
Let us now decide (d).
Let me write it in a different color.
15/11 minus 9/7.
Let us turn to a common denominator.
We are looking for a multiple of 11 and 7. I think it will be 77.
This is the first and least number,
which is shared by both.
We simply multiply the two numbers.
We get 77.
To get from 11 to 77, we should multiply it by 7.
15 by 7 is equal to 70 plus 35.
This is equal to 105.
Then we record minus. 77 is a denominator.
7 by 11 equals 77.
9 by 11 equals 99.
Then you get 105 minus 99 on 77.
How much is 105 minus 99?
It's equal to 6. And we're ready.
We can not simplify this liver anymore.
6 and 77 do not have common multipliers.
Let's solve (f).
Let's have a new color.
(f) states that we have 7/27 minus 9/39.
Okay, what is the common denominator equal here?
Actually here we have
an opportunity to simplify fractions.
We can make them a little easier.
At 9/39, both numbers are divided by 3.
I can record 9/39 here. 9 divided by 3 equals 3.
39 divided by 3 equals 13.
Then this expression becomes equal to 7/27 minus 3/13.
What is the common denominator for numbers 27 and 13?
They have no common dividers and therefore
we will simply multiply the two numbers.
We have 27 at 13. Let me write it down
on this side here.
We are looking for 27 at 13.
3 at 7 is 21. 1 and 2 in mind. 3 in 2 is 6, plus 2, is equal to 8.
Let's put 0 here.
1 in 7 is equal to 7.
1 in 2 equals 2.
Now we collect them.
1 plus 0 is 1.
8 plus 7 is 15.
1 plus 2 is 3.
We have something on the common denominator
minus another thing on 351.
To get 351 out of 27, we should multiply it by 13.
To get from 7 to the numerator here,
we should multiply it by 13.
7 at 13 is equal to 70 plus 21, i. E. 91.
This liver becomes 91/351.
To get 351 out of 13, we should multiply it by 27.
We multiply the numerator by 27.
3 at 27, which is 60 plus 21, i. E. 81.
The answer will contain a denominator 351.
91 minus 81 is equal to 10.
And we're ready.
Let's figure out another example.
These become a bit more difficult,
but we can deal with them.
(h) states 13/64 minus 7/40.
Let's look for a common denominator of 64 and 40.
80 will not happen.
We may try another. Let's actually try
in the traditional way.
Let's look at the multipliers.
Let's divide the two numbers into simple multipliers
and find the smallest total number.
This will be interesting.
Let me write 64 with another color.
We can divide it into 2 by 32, which is the same as
2 at 16, and 16 equals 2 at 8.
8 is the same as 2 in 4, and 4 is the same
such as 2 in 2.
We multiply two by one
three, four, five, six times.
It is obtained that 64 equals 2 in 2, 2,
2, 2, 2.
If you know what the degrees are, then it's the same
like having 2 at sixth.
That's for 64.
For 40 we will apply the same thing.
Let me write 40 with a different color.
40 is equal to 2 by 20, which is equal to 2 by 10 and 10 by 2 by 5.
We get that 40 is equal to 2 by 2, by 2, by 5.
So we decompose 40 to simple multipliers.
Now, if we compare the two numbers, then 2 by 2, 2
is also contained in 64.
We notice that there is no multiplier 5
in the simple multipliers of 64.
We have 2 2, 2.
To find the smallest common fold, here are these simple multipliers
simply multiply them by 5.
We take 64 and multiply it by 5.
Then there is 64 in the resulting number, but also
also contains the number 40.
That is, it's 64 at 5.
What is the equivalent of 64 in 5?
It ends my place here.
I will move to the right.
64 by 5 equals 320.
We have 320 after multiplying by 5.
If we multiply 64 by 5,
we should multiply by 13 by 5.
This is equal to 50 plus 15.
13 by 5 is equal to 65.
Then, to reach from 40 to 320, we should multiply it by 8.
We see it here in decomposition.
We have these three pairs, ie. 2 of third grade.
Then we multiply by 8 and we record here.
7 by 8 equals 56.
It is obtained that we have 65 minus 56, which equals 9.
That is 9/320.
It was a tough task, but we succeeded
to go through it.
Let's solve this last task here below.
Consider the 2/3 equation by x plus 1/2.
Well, y is equal to 2/3 of x plus 1/2.
Determine the change in y between x is equal to 1
and x is equal to 2.
All right.
Let us draw a small table with x and y.
For x equal to 1, what is equal to y?
We have 2/3 of 1 plus 1/2, which is equal
2/3 plus 1/2. The common denominator is 6.
2/3 is equal to 4/6 - after multiplying the liver by 2 - plus 1/2 or 3/6.
This is equal to 7/6.
All right.
Replace with x equal to 2.
Two thirds of 2 plus 1/2 are obtained,
which is equal to 4/3 plus 1/2.
The common denominator is again 6.
4/3 is equal to 8/6 after the liver is multiplied by 2.
Add 3/6 and get 11/6.
They want us to determine the change for y between x is equal to 1
and x is equal to 2.
That is, how bigger is this value for y,
when x is equal to 2, relative to this value, at x is equal to 1?
We compile the difference 11/6 minus 7/6 to find the change for y
between x is equal to 1 and x is equal to 2. 11 minus 7 equals 4,
on 6, which is equal to 2/3.
This answer makes sense because every time,
when x increases by 1, the expression for y
increases by another 2/3.
Reaching from x equal to 1 to x equal to 2, y increases by 2/3.